for the fifth day of Christmas we have
quite a mysterious package that arrived
from Switzerland no I think it was from
Germany it wasn't quite such a surprise
as you might think because when I turned
it over of course it had a terrific wax
seal nowadays people don't normally use
wax seals but it had a customs
declaration and it said on it guitar
plectrum so I knew what was inside and
it was far more mysterious than if I
didn't and inside is a plectrum for
plucking a guitar you can see I don't
know how to pluck a guitar it was made
specially for me by Patrick who Schmidt
now what's interesting about it is that
it contains strontium aluminate not pure
strontium aluminate but strontium
aluminate doped with a rare earth
element probably europium though he
didn't tell me which one so it glows in
the dark
it's nice and shiny and it feels like
plastic though it's a slightly strange
color it could almost be ivory but it's
a bit too green it contains europium and
when you shine light on it
the europium stores some of the absorbed
light energy and then lets it out over a
period of time strontium aluminate
itself that's a compound of strontium
aluminium and oxygen is not particularly
special when it comes to optical
properties but if you put in a rare
earth for example europium or sometimes
people put in dysprosium so that's why
I'm not certain because he didn't say
which one then the atoms of the rare
earth which are isolated rather like the
fruit in the Christmas cake they absorb
ultraviolet light which you can't really
see or short wavelength light
and then emit it in the visible light so
the material glows in the dark but it
emits light much more slowly than it
absorbs it so it will go on glowing in
the dark for several minutes after
you've illuminated it I'm not quite sure
why one would need a glowing plectrum
after all if you're looking at the
strings to see where you're plucking
you're probably not playing the guitar
properly but it is really fun and if I
look at it in my hand I can see it
glowing so for the fifth day of
Christmas we have a glowing guitar
plectrum for drinking receptacles three
chemical badges
two periodic table bed covers and one
piece of tartaric acid from a Swiss wine
barrel well it's sort of dr2 now so I
put it back to make one
it's another brilliant act of defiance
from Einstein together that Nazi regime
isn't it absolutely right tell me what
you think of this as a painting you look
at more paintings than me I mean I
really enjoyed Lieberman painted
Einstein more than once this is quite
rough and sketchy but it's it's lovely
you know in Stein looks rather pleased
with himself quite happy